hey guys I'm Yara I'm from Cronus and
today I will be reading some college
horror stories so let's get to it I
found out my first week of freshman year
that my roommate was a sleepwalker in
the middle of the night she suddenly
jumped on my bed and wiped her arms
across my mattress cover I screamed so
loud that it startled her but not enough
to wake her up I asked her what was
going on and she replied I'm sorry I
spilled my milk all over you and I
needed to wipe it I did not sleep at all
that night okay my question is did she
actually spill milk was she imagining it
is this a black her casued I wonder how
the rest of the year went though I want
to know like if this was only a couple
nights in do you just get used to it my
roommate and I woke up in the middle of
the night to a random clicking noise in
our room we found some random girl
shutting our door she sat down at my
roommates computer and started URIs
furiously typing I asked her what she
was doing in our room and she responded
with don't worry I'm fixing your taxes I
yelled at her which woke up my roommate
but she still didn't budge my roommate
went back to sleep in the girl casually
just walked out of the room you know I
wouldn't be mad at that though my major
plan is that once I get my degree I'm
gonna create a school and the only class
they'll teach is called ap common sense
and the major skill that they will be
teaching as how to file taxes and you
know I kind of want to sign this girl up
to teach the class I just it just makes
me wonder what was she doing beforehand
that inspired her to go into somebody's
room and file their taxes my brother was
an RA for three years and one time one
of the residents was keeping a goat in
their dorm it took him a few weeks to
finally bust the guy eventually they
found him walking the hallway with his
goat okay
I took I don't know how to respond to
that one it's almost like how did they
get the goat inside how did the goat get
into the dorm in the first place
it's a lot of creative people in college
as an RA we had to stay in the dorms for
a few days after residents have left for
the holidays and clean up cleaning the
community fridge we had found that one
of the freshman biology students have
decided to store their dead dissected
lab rat alongside everyone's food how
considerate that's amazing it's almost I
mean the thing is I've never stored a
rat in our fridge but I am infamous for
like having little experiments that I do
it cuz I used to just use all that
really like organic expensive food like
I'm gonna mix it all together and I'm
gonna do some chemical reaction with it
they're putting in times of having to
tell my brothers that that wasn't food
and not to eat it so I can kind of
relate a squirrel broke into my dorm
because the screen in my window was
broken I woke up one morning and he
found him crawling on the floor even
after we caught him and kicked him out
he always came to my closed window
looking for food squirrels don't like me
uh-huh there was a squirrel at my high
school and I had this one long walk it
would literally just follow me the
entire time but it was as though it was
waiting for me so I would see it as soon
as I open the door just be sitting there
and I had to like try and get into my
class safely without being attacked by a
squirrel
ten times
thanks for watching guys